bonsoir vous êtes supporter les fils 78
je vous propose une nouvelle fois de
suivre ce soir un débat autour de
l'europe le scrutin de liste à un tour
se déroule dimanche nous devrions
assister en france un nouveau record
d'abstention l'élection européenne qui
ne passionnent pas les français mélange
de déception de résignation mais aussi
forme de contestation toujours selon les
derniers sondages le front national pour
être arrivé en tête suivi de l'ump un
peu plus loin du ps et enfin d'europe
écologie elle est versé quatre
formations sont en plateau jean michel
fourgous candidat pour l'ump maire
d'elancourt michel christophoul
candidate ps élue d'opposition à
verneuil-sur-seine sur scène pardon et
mounir satouri candidat europe ecologie
les verts également président du groupe
écologiste à la région ile de france et
puis devraient nous rejoindre philippe
chevrier est le président du front
national également donc candidat dans
cette élection européenne bonsoir tout
d'abord à tous les trois et bienvenue en
plateau vous aurez trois quarts d'heure
pour échanger sur vos propositions pour
l'avenir de l'union mais tout d'abord ce
sont les yvelinois qui s'expriment
quelle décision doit prendre l'europe en
urgence vos priorités micro trottoir
je passe vers le fédéralisme
je pense que c'est une que c'est une
bonne voie c'est la priorité pour que
les gens puissent travailler c'est tout
le monde puisse travailler quoi c'est
tout mais bon pour le reste
de l'économie
en essayant de
lancer des grands travaux pour relancer
la demande voilà l'emploi en europe
vraiment c'est la priorité je pense
j'avais une politique commune
c'est-à-dire tout ce qui est social et
économique je crois que l'europe
aujourd'hui c'est une catastrophe pour
ce qui prime c'est l'égoïsme de chaque
pays peut-être un peu moins de le
conduire le pays dans l'europe parce que
c'est ingérable un
nombre de pays qui a déjà un oeuf d'où
ils avaient du mal à
pully non à nous parler de leurs
attentes pour l'europe de l'urgence du
moment protection sociale relance de
l'économie revient le plus souvent on a
aussi entendu l'europe c'est une
catastrophe ce qui prime c'est l'égoïsme
de chaque pays il faut une politique
commune alors je vais revoir et à voir
votre réaction rapide tout d'abord sur
cette cette déclaration on va a débuté
par un tour de table dans l'ordre
alphabétique et ensuite on se basera sur
le temps de parole les chronomètres qui
vont s'afficher régulièrement michel
christophoul donc candidate parti
socialiste quel est votre sentiment sur
cet égoïsme ressenti en tout cas par par
certains des concitoyens qu'ils nous
disent l'europe est replié chaque pays
est replié sur soi c'est une vérité
aujourd'hui je trouve que effectivement
c'est une grande vérité c'est même le
souci de nos jour d'hui qui
effectivement
où les états se replient sur eux-mêmes
alors que c'est effectivement le
contraire de l'idéal européen a priori
est ce qui a fait que l'europe a procuré
un espace de paix justement rompant avec
les échos les égoïsmes et les rivalités
d'autrefois et demi à deux reprises au
gouvernement par exemple le décret
alstom puisque c'est comme ça qu'il est
qu'il est baptisé du nom de cette
entreprise en attente de rachat établi
par arnaud montebourg et manuel valls
pour protéger les intérêts stratégiques
en france qui inquiète d'ailleurs à
bruxelles on parle de protectionnisme
c'est une bonne ou une mauvaise mesure
mes côtés je pense que c'est une bonne
mesure d'ailleurs elle est tellement
bonne qu'il ya beaucoup de pays qui
l'ont déjà prises les états unis et puis
des pays européens l'ont fait
l'allemagne de protection et puis non
c'est pas tout à fait du protectionnisme
jean michel fourgous candidat ump notre
réaction sur ce sentiment de payer
refermés sur eux-mêmes et peut-être sur
des craintes oui mais bon je pense que
les français
soient un problème c'est qu'ils sont
facilement négatif je vous rappelle
qu'on est le pays qu'elles moins
confiance en lui-même c'est vrai aussi
nos adolescences d'étudiants bon donc
voilà il faut il faut voir souvent ces
critiques dont beaucoup de critiques
soit sur l'europe sont assez injuste
l'europe n'est pas parfaite bien sûr
qu'il ya en des 28 étaient un petit peu
trop rapide vers l'europe dès 18 ya
quand même plusieurs cercles alors
l'europe des dix villes de la zone euro
ont déjà une grande cohérence bon mais
voilà vous ne peut pas être contre comme
cela ne nous laissons pas trop aller à
la critique il n'y a pas que des
critiques d'art dans les romains la
première attente des français ils l'ont
dit c'est l'emploi l'emploi eh ben c'est
c'est augmenter la production de
richesse augmenter le niveau des
échanges le nombre d'échangés t-il dans
que quand vous avez un marché d'un
milliard d'individus comme c'est le cas
de l'europe on ne rigole pas avec ça on
ne tombe pas à bras raccourcis là-dessus
ccc voilà c'est un merveilleux moyen
bien sûr d'augmenter la richesse le pib
l'emploi je vous rappelle que que tout
de même la france a comme premier client
l'europe
un tiers des emplois dépendent de
l'europe donc attention
effectivement certaines remarques sont
tout à fait juste et on doit améliorer
un sur deux choses un peu trop
fonctionnarisé un peu trop administratif
un peu alors les égoïsmes je sais pas
c'est un grand débat je pense que
l'europe est une réussite je vous
rappelle que l'europe est la première
puissance économique mondiale on oublie
très souvent de le rappeler enfin
ressoudés oui quelques années vous en
parler de paix tout à l'heure mais on a
quand même l'europe on a aussi produit
deux guerres mondiales la première 20
millions la deuxième chose millions de
morts la troisième c'était la guerre
froide avec les communistes quand
comment fermer 10 millions d'européens
derrière des murs avec des grilles en
quittant leur tirer dessus pour qu'il
voulait passer à l'ouest ils me
demandèrent et puis la quatrième c'est
le cochon bourbon donc je dirais quand
même que l'europe l'europe voilà c'est
fini c'est vous c'est un acquis social
de la paix vous l'avez ses formes hier
aujourd'hui c'est la première ce
sous-continent ce est il devenu la
première je préviens t rencontre mais
ils ont deux tables théorie un chat
souris europe ecologie les verts je vous
passe la parole juste nous accueillons
sur ce plateau philippe chevrier donc le
candidat du jour national bonsoir et
bienvenue pour ce débat nous parlions de
ce sentiment d' égoïsme ressenti parfois
par certains européens chaque payer est
replié sur lui-même est ce que vous le
ressentez ce que vous l'analysez comme
ça d'abord moi je trouve le
micro-trottoir qu'on nous avait présenté
plein de bon sens et je trouve même que
les habitants de 50 ans et demi vous
avez interrogé on résumer au final la
question
la somme des intérêts individuels n'a
jamais fait l'intérêt général et au
somment les citoyens que nous avons vus
ils ont dit quelque chose de très simple
c'est que nous souffrons d'un manque
d'europe et il faudrait aller plus loin
dans la construction européenne est en
période de crise en france et en europe
qu'est ce qu'ils nous ont dit les
citoyens ils nous ont dit qu'il fallait
une politique de relance européenne
qu'il fallait une politique de grands
travaux qu'il fallait inverser le cercle
vicieux delà de la crise pour que
l'europe soit auprès des peuples et
auprès des citoyens donc l'europe est
une belle idée
il faut qu'on en soit fier de cette
construction européenne il faut qu'on
regarde la situation telle quelle et
qu'on affronte les véritables problèmes
et qu'on apporte des réponses il faut
construire une europe beaucoup plus
cohérente il faut
simplifier les institutions il faut
remettre plus de démocratie dans les
décisions il faut donner plus la parole
au peuple et il faut sortir d'une
certaine technostructure que les
citoyens nous reproche donc cette
construction si ici et là on peut
entendre des critiques sur la
construction européenne ou sur les
institutions européennes je pense que le
que le besoin est de l' envie d'europe
et là il est prêt le besoin d'europe
exister philippe chevrier je vous passe
la parole vous venez nous rejoindre mais
on a écouté un micro trottoir tout à
l'heure où chacun exprimé ses priorités
pour l'europe et certains aux sorties
sans yvelinois conso de concitoyens
européens à parler d'une europe de pays
repliés sur eux-mêmes de certains
dysfonctionnements il fallait une
politique commune c'est pas forcément
sentiment que vous partagez n'ont de
toute façon le front national n'a jamais
demandé à ce qu'on se replie sur soi ça
ce sont nos adversaires politiques qui
prétendent que nous voulons faire cela
en nous voulons simplement protéger nous
les emplois
j'entendais monsieur fourgous là qui
nous parlaient d'emploi il est il est
quand même il a quand même un certain
toupet parce que c'est à cause de
l'europe justement des centaines de
milliers d'emplois sont partis à l'autre
bout de la planète donc elle nous parle
d'emploi il nous parle de l'europe comme
un pourcentage très important de
l'économie mondiale se serait sauf que
il oublie de nous dire que cette europe
c'est un ensemble de nations et que si
les nations étaient à nouveau souveraine
il y aurait exactement le même chiffre
exactement la même proportion ce n'est
pas à cause de la construction
européenne qu'on en est là le commerce
extérieur des pays des nations qui
composent donc cette europe n'a pas
augmenté en pourcentage de leur pib
depuis qu'on a créé l'europe c'est faux
ce serait faux de le dire on a continué
à commercer comme avant et avant au
commerce est tout à fait naturellement
avec des droits de douane ce n'est pas
le fait de mettre des droits de douane à
nos frontières
le fait d'un repli sur soi c'est
simplement le fait de commercer
intelligemment avec ses voisins c'est ça
le problème voilà donc
je pense que effectivement
les états nations ont besoin aujourd'hui
de retrouver leur souveraineté de
retrouver leurs monnaies nationales
de commercer intelligemment avec le
reste du monde de jouer avec leur
monnaie si besoin est et ainsi de
sauvegarder les emplois dans chacune des
nations car aujourd'hui le libre
échangisme et les portes ouvertes à
toutes et à tous les biens et services
produits dans le monde entier sont
consubstantiels de la constitution
européenne de la fin la constitution je
vais un petit peu vite parce qu'elle a
été refusée souvenez vous parler
français mais on l'a remis au goût du
jour je veux dire simplement de la
construction européenne voilà michel
christophe vous ne partagez pas cette
vision de l'europe pour le parti
socialiste mais vous voulez une europe
forcément unis mais comment l'europe
peut réussir à protéger les salariés à
protéger aussi ces entreprises puisque
c'est la question qui va nous intéresser
principalement aujourd'hui c'est la
question sociale la question également
de protection de l'économie développer
leur président tu es face aussi aux
autres pays du monde je vous passe la
parole tout d'abord puisque vous avez
une minute trente de retard avant de
revenir sur l'économie je voulais dire
mon voisin que
on est dans une unité politique mais on
est une somme d'états souverains
toujours et d'ailleurs nous au parti
socialiste nous comptons bien que ceux
ci perdure nous pouvons conjugués des
aspects de souveraineté et ses aspects
de souveraineté sont encore très
important aujourd'hui est en même temps
une unité parce que nous formons nous
avons d'ailleurs le micro-trottoir le
disais à nous avons un projet commun
depuis maintenant 60 ans
à une culture très proche et c'est à
préserver et donc fasse effectivement au
monde d'aujourd'hui donc je vais revenir
à l'économie nous nous considérons que
nous serons plus forts face à la
mondialisation face aux états continents
nous serons plus forts en gardant cette
union alors cela dit il ya des
évolutions et lâcherait d'accord avec
monsieur satory
il ya des évolutions démocratiques à
faire dans cette europe effectivement
mais tel n'est pas le sujet donc on y
reviendra peut-être tout à l'heure alors
il est nécessaire de se protéger
effectivement puisque nous sommes dans
un monde extrêmement concurrentiel dans
une mondialisation qui qui qui n'est pas
la première d'ailleurs il ya eu bien
d'autres mais en tout cas celle ci nous
prend de plein fouet et est un choc sur
le plan économique elle n'est pas
d'ailleurs elle n'est pas si récente que
cela mais en tout cas là elle atteint
des degrés extrêmement important en tout
cas on voit la situation aujourd'hui en
europe et je dois dire que c'est vrai
qu'on peut reprocher à l'europe
d'aujourd'hui de ne pas avoir su
résister à cette mondialisation de ne
pas avoir pris les directives et les les
directions nécessaire pour nous protéger
et jure concrète au parti socialiste au
niveau des socialistes en europe l'an
dernier m ampleur nous nous souhaitons
plusieurs choses et en particulier
profiter de ses échanges avec le monde
c'est vrai comme le disait monsieur
fourgous l'europe et la grande puissance
commerciale du monde ont en partie parce
que ya eu beaucoup d'échangés
l'intérieur c'est pas que les échanges
extérieurs
est une grande puissance commerciale l
échange avec le reste du monde mais il y
a des échanges qui sont inégaux parce
que c'est vrai que nous sommes en
concurrence avec des produits qui sont
fabriqués dans des conditions sociales
environnementales qui sont absolument
pas les mêmes que les nôtres est ce que
nous souhaiterions et ce serait une
grande avancée puisque ça permettrait à
notre europe d'avoir des ressources
propres ce dont elle manque cruellement
pour faire la relance dont dont vous
parliez pour laquelle nous sommes
effectivement partant parce que les
politiques d'austérité qui ont été mises
en place depuis dix ans par les
conservateurs excusez moi monsieur
froboess le ppe dont vous faites partie
effectivement on aboutit à cette
catastrophe 27 millions de chômeurs
selon les chiffres une centaine de
millions de personnes sous le seuil de
pauvreté donc nous ne souhaitons nous
souhaiterions que soit prise
effectivement à l'extérieur sur le
périmètre de notre europe par exemple
une taxe carbone qui permettraient
d'une part de donc enrichir notre budget
apporter des moyens qui pourraient être
réinvestis dans des grands projets et
nous sommes d'accord là dessus mais qui
pourrait protéger effectivement nos
entreprises jean michel fourgous oui
bonjour et revenir sur l'histoire des
détails joignable les entrepreneurs sse
et c'est vous dire qu'ils ont fait cette
robe je rappelle que jean monnet était
négociant en cognac mans donc bien sûr
que ça avant cette europe quand on
exportait quand on paye des taxes
douanières vous allez le empruntant du
front national a l'air de trouver que
bon c'était pas méchant pleurer et à
gaza vous rigolez ça coûte très cher ça
vous perdez du temps vous remplissez des
documents plusieurs langues mais mais
c'est une catastrophe on va beaucoup
moins commercer donc on fera beaucoup
moins de pib on fera beaucoup moins
d'emplois deuxièmement le change quand
avant vous aviez à changer votre monnaie
dans 30 rock api vous pourriez perdre
jusqu'à 20 30% de la valeur de un peu de
votre chiffre d'affaires regin par le
change on a même vu des gens qui avaient
déposé leur bilan parce qu'ils avaient
passé un accord dans un pays sur une
commande un certain taux et en quelques
mois ça avait changé et le type avait vu
manger toute sa marge bénéficiaire
pourquoi fais tu avais avait trahi
pourriez donc été obligé déposé son
bilan la maison au comment peut-on
aujourd'hui aux et c'est vrai que ce ce
ce taureau il est peut-être un peu trop
élevé mais c'est une réussite cette
théorie vous à protéger dans la crise
comment peut-on comme ça sortira une
table devant des millions
d'entrepreneurs dont le premier client
c'est l'europe comment peut-on sortir
osé sortir du riad cas je sais pas
marine le pen venu à jour en face de moi
sur françois je citerai mais quand elle
sort sa aidant elle en pense pas un mot
c'est de la stratégie marketing
émotionnel voilà le pays cette france
aujourd'hui il ya toujours un discours
sur les motions sur la façon de
manipuler le lectorat moi je touche je
dénonce là c'est grave y'a nos
entrepreneurs qui dépendent de ce client
qui dépendent bien sûr en plus ils ont
des partenaires financiers l'europe et
leur premier partenaire financier
commercial en même en termes de r&d
enfin comment peut-on attaqué la
première puissance mondiale après les
catastrophes dont je vous ai parlé de
l'europe souvient d'où l'on vient c'est
quand même mélange de même s'il y avait
effectivement des add des améliorations
apportées en tout cas sur cette histoire
de parler des douanes comme ça des
preuves benoît carette a bien mais vous
rigolez mais vous rigolez pas
professionnel de dire ça et jouir
l'économie c'est sérieux on fait trop
d'émotionnel dans ce pays si l'emploi
c'est vraiment la première attente que
tout à l'heure on le dire on arrête de
sortir n'importe quoi et d'oser dire que
il ya qu'à sortir de l'euro c'est pas
sérieux monsieur fourgous alors que les
entreprises ferment sans arrêt les ans
de l'avoir française disparaît ce qu'est
ce que cela ne tienne pas le coup
vis-à-vis des entreprises allemandes
mettez vous osez dire ça mais dieu merci
mais c'est vous qui n'est pas sérieux là
monsieur faudra vous allez 57 % de
dépenses publiques du pib grâce
d'ailleurs aux 35 heures qui ont ils se
la voir 5 grâce à la retraite à 60 ans
ils ont créé
pour dire ce qui est on voit donc voilà
les raisons de ce décrochage économique
entre la france et l'allemagne vous avez
raison le souligner bien sûr c'est ça le
problème le décrochage de 12 points 57 %
de dépenses publiques du pin en france
et 45 en allemagne et un peu moins 40
roche croit que et bien voilà ça il faut
améliorer ça mais c'est pas ça rien à
voir l'allemagne est ce que l'allemagne
l'allemagne est le halal euros là je
vous interromps tous les deux je vais
passer il faut mais tout d'abord mona
lisa ils sont d'accord à tanger le temps
il faut il faut il faut à chaque
élection était parlement quand vous êtes
on quand vous avez vous ne vous imaginez
pas
j'aimerais bien être profitez-en venir
satory c'est le moment ou jamais
chez les verts on a fait la moitié du
chemin on a construit l'europe de
l'union commerciale on a construit le
charbon on la construit l'acier et on a
avancé au fil des années des décennies
dans la construction européenne
aujourd'hui on au milieu du chemin
certains comme vous réponds c'est qu'il
faut faire marche arrière et revenir en
arrière d'autres pensent qu' il faut en
rester là et amélioré à la maj n'oppose
qu'il fallait plus loin et qu'il faut
construire l'école leur fédéral on a
construit une monnaie unique
et on n'a pas construit en face les
institutions politiques qui permettent
de piloter la politique économique et
monétaire et je pense que ça aujourd'hui
on est face à une véritable difficulté
rapport à nos institutions on peut pas
saucissonné on peut pas dissocier la
question de la construction
institutionnelle de la question
démocratique et de la place des peuples
et de la question du développement
économique alors là où on pourrait
peut-être se mettre d'accord c'est qu'il
faut un véritable plan de relance
ambitieux pour aider et accélérer le
processus de sortie de la crise les
écologistes vous n'allez pas être
surpris on est pour un plan de relance
sur la question des transports à la
question des énergies l'isolation
thermique la balance commerciale des
pays européens que l'union européenne et
négatives principalement à cause de
factures énergétiques nous avons un
devoir de réduire à l'échec hors pair la
facture énergétique et de baisser notre
dépendance par rapport au pétrole que
n'avons pas dans nos pays donc il faut
investir de manière massive sur la
question des économies d'énergie de
l'isolation thermique et ça permet de
relancer et de le deuxième point 80 %
des entreprises européennes sont des pme
et tpe
il faut donc soutenir les petites et les
moyennes entreprises et il faut investir
sur la question de l'innovation
aujourd'hui par exemple sur la
fabrication des produits nous n'avons
pas forcément besoin de faire plus mais
de faire mieux nous avons un devoir
d'exemplarité en europe pour qu'au
moment au produit on pense aussi à
l'après vie du produit à son recyclage
et je pense que les nouvelles
technologies l'innovation un plan de
relance exemplaires sur la question de
l'énergie des transports d'ailleurs ça
traître a en partie la question d'alstom
je pense que l'investissement sur la
question des transports en commun ça
relance aussi ça maintient notre
industrie européenne exemplaire sur ces
questions là donc on a des forces au
niveau de l'europe on a des questions
institutionnelles et de construction à
régler mais je suis d'accord sur propos
du début il faut qu'on arrête de
regarder nos faiblesses et qu'on se
mobilise pour faire mieux plus vite
parce que les citoyens attendent des
réponses j'aimerais présent que les
temps de parole sa fiche et vous verrez
que pour l'ump jean michel fourgous et
est en avance d'à peu près une minute
vous êtes à peu près à égalité quatre
minutes c'est c'est philippe chevrier
pardon qui est en retard d'à peu près
une minute sur le temps de parole c'est
donc à vous que je vais passer la parole
avec cette question est ce
qu'aujourd'hui l'europe et est armé pour
résister aux autres pays
notre puissance aux puissances
émergentes en puissance existantes les
états unis non justement tous les
résultats en fait d'une
cette escroquerie du siècle dernier où
on a essayé de faire avaler aux gens
avec succès d'ailleurs que plus on était
gros et plus on était puissant fort est
apte à résister aux à la chine par
exemple ont pointé la chine ont pointé
des états unis les grands continents les
maintenant aujourd'hui on dirait les
briques bon
c'est totalement faux on voulait bien on
voit bien qu'il ya des petits pays dans
le monde qui ont parfaitement résisté à
la mondialisation alors que cette europe
un mal fou à réagir par exemple à des ad
des changements brutaux de
l'environnement économique on l'a vu
vis-à-vis des etats-unis quand les états
unis sont protégés à plusieurs reprises
vis-à-vis par exemple des pneus chinois
mais pas seulement ils sont aussi
protégés
d'investissement chinois ont chez eux
ils savent réagir vite
leur rock ne s'est pas à réagir vis
forte fatalement puisque comme vous le
disiez d'ailleurs très bien c'est que la
construction politique et qui aurait dû
que réélu selon les constructeurs de
loeb qui aurait dû se mettre en marche
ne s'est pas mise en marche et ce qui
est intéressant c'est pas tellement
constat c'est le pourquoi pourquoi ça ne
s'est pas mis en marche je vais vous
trouvez des excuses finalement c'est
parce que vos partenaires bien n'en
veulent pas c'est simple pour le vous
refusez de voir la france l'europe
pardon ce n'est pas la france ont plus
grands lors de la france dans l'europe
c'est de 11 à 13% de droit de vote c'est
ça qu'il faut bien comprendre et qu' il
ya un autre pays qui s'appelle
l'allemagne qui est beaucoup plus
important et qui en plus à des pays
satellites autour qui qui vont dans le
même sens que l'allemagne et qui fait
qu' il ya une puissance importante en
europe qui contrebalance tout ce que les
partis politiques français pro européens
veulent et donc il se heurte en
permanence à cela vous disiez tout à
l'heure je souhaiterais où je voudrais
qu'il y ait un tarif avec des droits de
douane à l'extérieur de l'europe aux
frontières de l'europe voit la taxe
carbone bonjour joue un petit peu sur
les mots mais
le tarif extérieur commun existait
pourquoi ne l'avez vous l'avez vous
laisser disparaître vous étiez aussi aux
manettes vous avez vous citiez tout à
l'heure le ppa mais le ps main dans la
main avec le ppe s'est débarrassé ce
tarif extérieur commun et pourquoi parce
que tu es répondre pourquoi parce que
c'est tout ça une substantielle de la
construction européenne et que vous n'y
pouvez rien nous vous pouvez toujours
dire y'a qu'à il faut à chaque élection
sauf que après les français voient bien
que rien ne se passe et que la misère
s'installe que le chômage augmente que
chez christofle oui alors je voulais
remercier
mon collègue vers d'abord d'avoir
ressentez recentrer le débat parce que
là nous étions par les parties dans des
débats de posture n'est ce pas sur les
doigts voilà lé débat de postures alors
l'ump qui évoque les 35 heures à propos
de la construction européenne par
exemple et qui dans son clip de campagne
appelle à voter contre le président
unique au monde
qui appellent à voter contre le
président de l'afrique ce qui est un
mensonge parce que le 26 mai les
français ont toujours le même président
de la république donc c'est quand même
dommage qu'on perde eu tant de temps à
ne pas parler de l'essentiel alors la
posture chez vous elle est aussi la même
on a entendu parler du mps alors là
c'était pps a une petite variante de
l'ump s non nous ne faisons pas du tout
la même chose le fait même le coup oui
non et 1 14% des directives voulaient
voter avec vos amis du pp il fort
national n'est jamais là pour les bottés
l'instant je vois vous et des députés
pour l'instant
ça va arriver sauf on
voulait la parole
voilà donc je voulais recentrer le débat
sur sur l'économie et effectivement il
faut relancer l'économie et là nous ne
sommes pas du tout sur les mêmes
positions le candidat de monsieur à la
pour la commission européenne le
candidat monsieur fourgous c'est
monsieur juncker qui est le président
l'ancien premier ministre du luxembourg
paradis fiscal comme chacun sait ça
tombe mal ça tombe mal à une époque où
il semble se dégager au moins sur les
estrades et autour des plateaux un
espèce de consensus pour lutter contre
les paradis fiscaux je rappelle qu' il y
à 1000 milliards d'évasion fiscale
chaque année et que le petit les petites
avancées que nous faisons vont permettre
là aussi de récupérer une partie mais il
ya effectivement beaucoup de choses à
modifier dans ce domaine et là la
position du ps et de martine chose qui
est notre candidat
le candidat gay 28 p parti socialiste
puisque nous avons à la fois un
programme commun nous sommes présents
dans les 28 pays et ça c'est une force
en tout cas pour mettre une politique
vous parliez de souveraineté tout à
l'heure on voit que de façon
transversale au delà des souverainetés
il ya quand même des opinions politiques
et des programmes communs et qui veulent
justement rompre à et prendre à bras le
corps à bras le corps le problème de
l'évasion fiscale comme le problème du
dumping social 1 et là si on parle de la
directive détachement les socialistes
ont fait en sorte de faire avancer le
dossier pour éviter pour améliorer cette
directive qui était effectivement
extrêmement détourné de son objectif
premier était la protection qui
protégeait les français qu'ils allaient
travailler à l'étranger mais là qui se
retournait nous avons fait au niveau du
ps et notamment pervenche bérès qui est
ma tête de liste et dont je suis très
fier puisque rarement elle a dit
sandrine
termine juste 1 est donc là nous ne
sommes pas du tout sur les mêmes
positions donc je refuse effectivement
qu'on nous métier dans la même case il a
aussi bien vous êtes une fois ce qui
brille jean michel fourgous si vous
souhaitez réagir et ensuite je passerai
la parole aussi à mounir satory parce
que j'aimerais vous entendre sur ce un
traité de libre-échange qui est négocié
avec les états unis également europe
ecologie les verts est plutôt critique
les grands partis on les entend pas
souvent mais europe écologie en tout cas
s'est exprimée est plutôt contre et
j'aimerais ça va avoir votre sentiment
savoir si l'europe aujourd'hui arrive
quand même à imposer sa voix ou doit
subir ce que les autres puissances leur
impose mais est tout d'abord jean michel
fourgous si vous souhaitez réagir bon
d'abord notre un univers souligné tolère
le premier des grands chantiers du
centre est important vous ne pouvez pas
aujourd'hui un nouvel avion par exemple
ces 15 milliards de r & d on veut pas la
france le pays donc il faut dire que ce
soit ça ne peut être qu'un une recherche
européenne c'est vrai d'éditeur pour
l'énergie c'est vrai d'un drone
aujourd'hui on n'a pas réussi à faire
décoller un drone parce qu'on n'a pas
trouvé une il faut une synergie
européenne c'est clair
deuxièmement sur l'épreuve jean
l'entente des primes de mots de
protection protection et on parlera du
traité avec les américains le cognac par
les chinois ont voulu récemment
sanctionné le cognac bon la france a dit
ne c'est pas gentil tension monte en
flèche et moi rien à faire l'europe yop
j'appelle au nom de la france vous
enlevez les taxes sur le cognac sinon
nous on bloque aussi d'autres d'autres
importations chez nous pourquoi les
chinois tout de suite on est et le sud
est nommé monsieur si on peut même plus
plaisante excusez nous on plaisante et
et il sortir immédiatement bien sûr les
surtaxes sur le produit français et
cognac donc il faut bien voir que en
termes de protection ça sert à quelque
chose à vous protège l'europe s'est il
ensuite l'évasion fiscale vous ai parlé
de symbole alors l'évasion fiscale
laboratoire sur le tour notre ne
comprenait pas que la triche fiscal vous
aidera il est nul milliards dont nous ça
c'est un chiffre que débats lancés il ya
il ya des capitaux qui partent pourquoi
pourquoi parce que et d'ailleurs est ce
que vous socialiste de les faire
accepter par votre candidature au niveau
européen vos spécificités la socialiste
française un impôt sur les sociétés à
38% alors qu'il était à 24%
en europe 1 hier à 75% un impôt sur le
revenu ils ont osé faire le ménage chez
eux et c'est moi qui
fais tous les talents vous croyez que
les socialistes européens ils vont vous
point de vue trier à 75% êtres votre
plus value si vous venez d'être évaluée
à 60 % plus value à 60% on monte une
société ici qu'au bout de au bout de
cinq ans vivant en france où on prend 60
% de labeur la boîte c'est 0 % en
belgique 0 % au luxembourg 0 % en suisse
ont continué le net ce drame est lié aux
socialistes qui ont fui les esprits et
fait ça mais partir 600 milliards
d'actifs financiers vous croyez qu'ils
vont vous prendre votre réussite ils ont
le surtout pas c'était des recettes et
les 35 heures par un seul pays a suivi
d'une façon mobile et on a généralisé
les 35 heures la retraite assure t-on
idem vous croyez qu'ils veulent votre
automne ils sont à 65 ans en europe vous
croyez qu'ils veulent les socialistes
français c'est quand ils vous appellent
les socialistes européens il vous
appelle il dispose est plus proche des
communistes des socialistes donc il faut
aussi se le dire
si vous souhaitez réagir et puis sur
cette question de deux traités de libre
échange avec les états unis la case et
puis on va essayer de parler d'europe
elle parlait simplement et de manière la
plus pédagogique possible à nos
concitoyens parce que bon vous pouvez
polimiquer toute l'assemblée je pense
que ça fait pas avancer l'europe ça fait
pas avancer ce qui est européen mais en
attendant laissez moi d'exprimer d'abord
cette campagne aura au moins servi à
faire parler du traité taffetas
alors à au moins servi à mettre sur la
place publique ce que ça commence à des
citoyens commencent à s'y intéresser
dont un certain nombre de radios etc les
auditeurs commencent à appeler à
s'interroger à réagir c'est
invraisemblable
nous assistions à une négociation par un
commissaire européen dont le secret est
quasiment le plus total et dans le dos
des peuples de ce qui fait l'essence
même de ce que nous sommes en europe au
clair ce qui était préparé derrière
cette négociation c'est de faire sauter
tous les verrous
sociaux écologiques et de normes
sanitaires et permettent à ce que les
entreprises américaines ou chinoises
parce qu'elle pense que certaines
décisions prises par nos pays où nos
collective et puissent porter plainte et
nous forcer à assouplir leurs règles je
vous donne un exemple à travers ce
traité
l'industrie du tabac pourrait porter
plainte contre entre nos pays parce que
notre loi nous empêchent de fumer dans
les lieux publics et que du coup ils
peuvent en déduire que ça baisse leurs
revenus et leurs bénéfices
voyez l'importance du fij et donc on est
à l'heure de la mondialisation
moi je ne suis pas d'accord avec
monsieur chevrier c'est pas vrai ça
viendra c'est pas vrai à l'heure de la
mondialisation
on peut pas faire croire aux français
que seul on y arrivera mieux car 28
pourquoi aujourd'hui le maire vous
n'êtes pas à 100 mais entendons visé
maintenant maintenant là le débat je
pense le débat qui intéresse les
français c'est qu'elle est l'europe
qu'on veut comme on l'a construit et
comment on la fait vivre et qu'elle
contrôle ils ont en tant que citoyen sur
elle
l'europe à uccle au dollar pendant des
années parce qu'il faut quand même
remettre les points sur les i pendant
des années et des années les gouvernent
nos chefs de gouvernement et d'état
allait négocier avec leurs partenaires
un certain nombre de décisions et quand
il revenait face aux électeurs qui
disait c'est pas nous c'est l'europe et
l'europe c'est aussi les chefs d'états
et de gouvernements en europe moi je
pense que il faut accélérer la
construction démocratique il faut
réaffirmer notre identité et nos règles
il faut que l'europe affiche ses normes
sanitaires ces normes sociales ces
normes environnementales et part d'une
seule voix et c'est ça qui fera
qu'on pèse dans la compétition
internationale sai on parle ensemble
avec n'aurait dû nos valeurs et en nous
imposant dans le débat ou mondia qu'on
arrivera à faire avancer à défendre nos
intérêts et pour revenir sur
mais ce qui préoccupe nos concitoyens on
a construit le libre échange pendant des
années je pense qu'aujourd'hui il est
temps d'avancer sur les normes sociales
et qu'il faut être dans une logique de
convergence au niveau européen la
question du smig on peut pas tolérer au
moment où
chacun des pays européens parce que on
peut pas décréter du genre un smic parce
que les niveaux de vie les pib des 27 28
pays sont pas les mêmes mais il faut
immédiatement posé le tracé du smic dans
chacun des pays européens et travailler
à une convergence son fils au fixons des
objectifs précis dans le temps cd
convergence des normes sociales et donc
il faut que les français puissent être
assurés sur leur force est leur capacité
nous nous sommes un grand pays nous
pouvons porter un message dans le monde
et en europe et on peut participer à
faire avoir par exemple concluant le mon
sens le temps passe et nous allons
bientôt arriver sur la toute dernière
séquence où chacun pourra livrer sa
conclusion mais philippe chevrier tout
d'abord la décision si le front national
s'il est partie semblable au fonds
national dans le reste de l'europe
arrive en tête c'est quoi on sort de
l'euro on revient à chacun a sa monnaie
nationale on quitte l'europe pour fermer
les frontières
pas se faire comme ça ça va se faire
dans la concertation posée aux électeurs
lors des noms mais bien sûr d'avoir
échoué quand même revenir sur l'île
lorsque ce que je viens ce que vient oui
oui c'est très intéressant puisqu'elle
vient de donner à notre avis qui est
tout à fait intéressant et tout à fait
sympathique sauf que à chaque fois ils
ont tous servi comment ses phrases par
il faut il faut il faut il faut je lui
conseillerais de dire il faudrait parce
que malheureuses et notre programme
c'est gênant non mais je ne conteste pas
ce que vous dites je dis simplement que
vous n'êtes pas tout seul quoi et que
vous avez un score équivalent je vous
permets de le rappeler on ne pèse que 11
à 13% des droits de vote et que vous
avez d'autres états dans l'europe qui ne
veulent absolument pas ce que vous venez
de dire voilà donc je crains que vous
ayez beaucoup de
de problème avec ça dans le futur bon le
traité
transatlantique et évidemment je suis
d'accord avec vous c'est une honte que
ce sas tout ceci se soit passée sous le
sous le manteau que maintenant on en
parle un petit peu parce que c'est les
élections on sait toujours pas on
connaît toujours mal il est franchement
nous au front national on ne fait même
accompli en info
c'est mon point de vue alors ne faire
payer quand même que le dans le mandat
de négociation il est quand même par
exemple exception culturelle
d'exception culturelle donc compris dans
toutes les ambassades missions or la
culture la culture c'est une option
insultes anciennes alors excusez moi
j'avais pris un peu de temps de parole
vous m'avez rendu la pareille donc mais
l'axé vrai que la culture pour la france
est exceptionnel sauf que ça fait pas
d'accord d'accord les ondes et zélé
loire les aigles vont apprécier donc ce
traité ce traité nous ne faisons
absolument pas confiance aux
négociateurs de notre côté parce que
c'est parce que jamais depuis 50 ans ils
ont su défendre les intérêts de la
france donc je ne vois pas pourquoi
aujourd'hui
sachant si
vous êtes à peu près tout cela leur a
laissé sur leur sembleront sa valeur en
question bien évidemment sinon avec
l'euro on va dans le mur c'est évident
c'est écrit l'euro va exploser les
tensions sont telles entre ceux qui
réussissent bien sûr qu'ils ne
réussissent pas entre ceux qui
réussissent lors de l'offre phare et
français en particulier qui dont les
entreprises ferment en permanence parce
qu'elles ne sont plus compétitives ce
n'est plus si ce n'est plus viable donc
moi je te faire une pause à présent pour
afficher vos temps de parole comme ça
chacun ensuite vers le temps qui lui
reste pour conclure juste le temps de
rappeler que trente et une liste se
présente en ile de france cette année
c'est un record la moyenne en france en
2009 une vingtaine de listes beaucoup de
candidatures quelquefois inconnu en tout
cas il y aura forcément une qui vous
permettra de vous exprimer dans
l'isoloir sachez qu'il faut attendre les
3% de voix pour obtenir le remboursement
de sa campagne électorale voilà lé nom
qui est des filets les temps de parole
qui vont elles s'affichaient à présent
que chacun puisse avoir la parole si on
peut juste ma fille chez les temps qu'il
reste pour chacun donc tout d'abord pour
la conclusion ce sera jean michel
fourgous qui s'exprimera en premier
puisque vous avez 7 à 7 minutes 03 voilà
c'est prêt si cette affiche et allez y
si vous souhaitez conclut réagir
peut-être à ce qui reste vous avez à peu
près rennais très vite on a parlé très
vite du couple notre collègue du front
social dit on n'existe pas l'écran c'est
bon c'est pas moi c'est le couple franco
allemand qui a quand même créé cette
europe 1 aujourd'hui le couple franco
allemand il est affaibli par la part
j'irai le la faiblesse de françois
hollande qui n'était pas fait pour cette
fonction bon en tout cas voilà donc
voilà madame merkel souffre de cela le
couple est complètement déséquilibrée
bon sous sarkozy c'était quand même
autre chose pour régler les crises etc
ce n'était pas le même niveau mais bon
ce couple franco allemand le pibe de
l'allemagne plus la france ses deux
tiers du pipe chinois vous savez
mais bien bien mais c'est le couple
central c'est ce couple qui doit piloter
qui doit donner l'impulsion bien sûr
alors donc il s'agit bien sûr de
remettre des acteurs qui sont crédibles
monsieur harlem désir n'est pas crédible
non plus donc on veut des acteurs
crédibles je peux vous dire à l'ump
j'aimerais pas parfaite mais on a des
gens crédibles monsieur lamassoure
quelqu'un de crédible ensuite sur le
côté du avec les américains on commence
à dire ça y est à la méfiance typique
front national s'est tout de suite
négatif faut se méfier il faut faire
mais faussement ça se passe pas du tout
comme ça moche exporter plus simple avec
les années un crime a terminé mais
pourquoi c'est très difficile de
d'exporter aux états unis donc donc ce
traité c'est à la demande des français
pourquoi vous commencez à vous en méfiez
parce que vous connaissez pas ou
connaissez pas les résultats ce traité
bon pourquoi commencer a déjà dire que
que ça va mal se passer il ya des il ya
des variables effectivement sur le plan
sanitaire social environnemental
économique etc c'est bien sûr les
européens qui mènent qui mène qui mène
la danse pourquoi commencer à dire que
ça va forcément favorable aux etats-unis
non c'est pas l'objectif est plus
derniers mois
si vous déclenchez la sortie de l'euro
il ya même des études de l'union
européenne qui le disent vous allez
provoquer une chute de 20 à 40 % de tous
les actifs financiers vous avez ruiné
les miens rond vous allait ruiner les
efforts
les salariés étaient tous les ans un
grand nombre de dépôts de bilan
faux
les interrompt que chacun puisse
conclure à venir cette fois c'est avant
l'europe est la première puissance
économique au monde c'est la zone
qui a le moins difficile c'est la zone
dans la dette est la moins élevée
faisant nous confiance faisons lui
confiance nous avons besoin de mieux
d'europe nous vous avons besoin de plus
d'europe nous avons besoin d'une europe
des grands travaux une europe de la
relance ils n'auront de la transition
énergétique de la transition écologique
et pin in en europe de la démocratie et
des peuples la construction européenne
il faut l'achever et faisant nous
confiance parce que nos forces sont
importantes
oui alors nous avons eu un débat
essentiellement centré sur l'économie on
a beaucoup parlé du mot peuple nap donné
par la culture on a foncièrement pas
beaucoup
vous plaît
enfin bon
en tout cas on n'a pas beaucoup parlé de
social et c'est bien là la question
c'est que au fond votre robe monsieur
fourgous cei que vous faites depuis dix
ans c'est quand même celle qui a
sacrifié les travailleurs et les
personnes au profit de la finance de la
monnaie non du
don qu est donc ce que nous souhaitons
nous c'est que enfin un changement de
majorité nous permettent de choisir
notre europe juge arbore ce badge sépare
plus de rang - d'europe c'est
choisissons notre europe et le choix de
notre europe à nous socialistes français
mais aussi européens derrière martin
schulz c'est de faire enfin une europe
sociale une europe pour les peuples
un bel idéal qui était celui porté par
les pères de l'europe en tout cas ne pas
sacrifier comme vous l'avez fait pendant
dix ans les droits sociaux parce que on
est dans un raid dans une régression de
précision voire même et je voulais
terminer là dessus en double il ya
beaucoup de ce grand lésé puisque je
suis la seule femme dans suis désolé je
tends pas au final c'est dommage c'est
pas du malékisme sont en tout cas dans
ses droits sociaux des 30e cueillez pas
de régression non plus pour le droit des
femmes merci michel christophe le
philippe chevrier vous avez la zone euro
c'est zéro croissance c'est un chômage
de masse voilà ce que c'est donc il faut
en sortir rapidement et que les gens
soient rassurés il n'y aura pas de
baisse de pouvoir d'achat parce que ce
qui va se passer c'est que cette zone
marque qui restera sera très nettement
réévalué est très nettement demandé sur
les marchés financiers et vous le savez
très bien et y'aura pas aucune aucun
besoin de voir le front déprécier hier à
aucun besoin car vis-à-vis du dollar le
franc résiste bien le taux d'inflation
en france n'a pas été supérieur à celui
des états unis grâce à yao ndré et et
les perspectives budgétaires
que le front national met en avant
consultez son programme vont rassurer
les marchés financiers il n'y a aucune
raison absolument aucune pour que le
franc soit attaquée sur les marchés
financiers demain quand il sentira de la
zone euro merci fils au front national
philippe chevrier merci à vous quatre
d'être venus débattre sur ce plateau
l'étang paroles qui s'affichent vous
êtes tous à peu près à 9 minutes et fier
de la campagne s'est aussi à suivre sur
le journal régulièrement à 18h en direct
sur tv fils également sur le site
internet pour le replay est d'ailleurs
l'intégralité de ce débat est
consultable dès à présent merci à tous
les quatre et merci à vous bien sûr